[Musik]
hey sie willkommen wie heute zu einem
neuen blog ich gestehen ich kenne ein
paar tagen wurden unfassbar viele
kommentare und habe meine instagram
bilder geschrieben von wegen hashtag
blog camberg was wollt ihr denn weniger
beliebt wissen hat langweilig ich habe
nur ein mülleimer
ich habe mir neue stativ fürs auto
gekauft einem das kann ich euch zeigen
das ist die gleiche schublade
das ist auch was das hier dass sie das
ding habe ich mir bestellt
jetzt ist kaputt
also diese stative könnten wir gleich
mal testen bei mir im auto und ja besser
block konnte endeavour hat andere kommen
wollte bei 38 köln bonn stationieren
wollen wir für unseren neuen von karten
albig und oben ja wenn man ihn wirklich
dick und doof fand übrigens von allen
leuten die bei mir in der wohnung waren
und auf meiner tafel hier im bad
unterschrieben hat sandra einfach am
fettesten und am hässlichsten
unterschrieben aber passt dazu ihren
schuhen ist auch mit dabei heute also
ich würde es andere auf jeden fall
gleich vom hauptbahnhof ab haben dann
werden wir in ein paar folgen unserem
top platz aufnehmen der demnächst raus
kommt flugs beste bay einfachzucker pur
ich nehme für sandra auch eine kleine
überraschung wird ich hoffe das gefällt
ja sogar mal gucken ob die scheiße jetzt
funktioniert läuft also das teil jeweils
mir extra fürs auto bestellt habe kann
man auf jeden fall direkt in die tonne
kloppen
kamerad junge wog ist dies an 3d garnet
auto drehen jetzt und lag bei local
stück so dass auch ich habe ich übrigens
jetzt arbeitslos selber habe sondern ich
habe vergessen
[Applaus]
helfen sie köln flaschenöffner trost sie
uns auf der karte ist für die größte
teil der leute wir fahren jetzt auf
jeden fall nach hause und wir nehmen
jetzt das logo foto keine ahnung was von
dem podcast auf und ich hab mir gedacht
dass ich mich da drauf setzen anders
stellt ja immer daneben
wie heißt er auf instagram laser luca ok
perfekt so war das heute nicht so viel
passieren das habe ich ein paar folgen
auf jeden fall einige werde die anfragen
vorbereitet und ich habe sehr viel mehr
funktioniert dr
[Musik]
werde er nackt auf einer kugel
wer single sterben wer würde er ein im
bestand
[Musik]
rheinberg
wer im restaurant auf den tisch
duales tag werden würde er eine woche in
der wildnis übernehmen
junges hälfte werde er sein leben lang
auf macdonald verpflichten verzichten
werde er eine seiner nieren von kaufen
um zu überleben
leute wir nehmen jetzt unsere erste
podcast folge auf nummer sicher geht die
erste podcast folge von sonder und mir
online aber wir nehmen jetzt erstmal auf
aber mein ticket zurück ja schon gesehen
ich habe das recht weg wunsch drei
stunden aufgenommen werden dieser
aufgenommen im winter aufgenommen wir
haben die ersten zwei folgen haben an
dem wir nicht produktiv als exklusiv für
euch jetzt hier in diesem blog hört ihn
nun als allererstes die ersten sekunden
unsere ersten podcast folge was guckst
du so was musst du nicht manchmal mir na
ja er hat so rückschau auf kommando
dicker nein man du ich kann gar nicht
wissen
lösung kann wohl dass ich singen lieber
nicht machen wir nochmal hier die pkk
[Applaus]
walter folge auf
ducati ja was ist passiert mein pc
verwischen podcast folgen
wenn wir es gerade die dritte folge von
dem podcast dick und doof aufgenommen
und jetzt laufen wir gerade zum
hauptbahnhof bisschen wie beim auto und
alter das sind meine spur und dann ran
das war richtig investieren langfristig
auch nicht so darauf hin dass endlich
auch ihr lernt vor allem luca auch im
podcast noch mal auf eine ganz andere
art und weise kennen
safe viel intensiver über lena du redest
viel so viel 14 stück als
fünfundzwanzigster 17 uhr kommen die
erste folge der geldhäuser vernetzung
barlow für mausetot
sandra ist jetzt wieder abgecheckt die
habe ich gerade hauptbahnhof gebracht
und da habe ich wieder abgeholt weil die
beim friseur
ein kleiner gehen auf jeden fall von
wird wieder nach hause und habe mein
leben ist hat ranga ich halte was wollt
ihr denn wenig kanton hupen gemacht seit
mittwochabend sagt koren hat seitdem
nichts gegessen
seit 840 schon und jetzt gerade zum
ersten mal wieder aber sind es einfach
nur so kuriose mit ein bisschen obst
alter um karl ich könnte niemals 48
stunden nichts essen da will ich den
blog an der stelle jetzt auch beenden
ich habe dir doch eigentlich nur gemacht
weil so viele von euch mal wieder ein
blog gewünscht haben und dann habe ich
gedacht hätte ich noch mal neu
ja so bei jura dass ich mir meine neue
autoscheiben halterung für die kamera
wir können allerdings sagen das hat den
komplett bescheuert ist dann habe ich
aber irgendwie dennoch die ganzen tag
eigentlich nur geblockt wie ich mit
sandra schwachsinn gemacht habe
eigentlich damals getroffenen podcast
aufzunehmen das haben wir auch gemacht
allerdings fördermenge schwachsinn
gemacht hat schon die ersten zehn
minuten gerade die fans bisher auf jeden
fall würde ich die glocke an der stelle
jetzt auch beenden die bereits gesagt
wenn es euch gefallen hat das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da wollte das nicht mehr glaube also in
meinem leben geht halt wirklich nicht so
viel ab aber vielleicht ist es ja
dennoch irgendwie also ich kann mir gar
nicht was unterhaltsames trainiert ein
kanalfest noch kein teil der lukb am 25
nur kommt die erste folge von sandra in
einem podcast beckedorf
ich dachte ich muss nicht rücken
[Musik]